Back in the '90s, there weren't many comedians
quite as big as Jeff Foxworthy.
His relatable humor about being a regular
guy from the South endeared him to millions…and
so did his extremely popular "you might be
a redneck" jokes.
"My definition of redneck, it is a glorious
absence of sophistication."
Foxworthy's albums sold so well that he became
the most successful comedy recording artist
of all time.
He also starred in his own network sitcom,
hosted Are You Smarter Than a Fifth Grader?
and headlined the Blue Collar Comedy Tour
with Bill Engvall, Larry the Cable Guy, and
Ron White.
Today, Foxworthy isn't the white-hot king
of comedy he once was, but he's still got
a huge following and keeps very busy.
Here's what he's been up to lately.
Becoming a salesman
Fans might not see Foxworthy's shows or stand-up
specials while flipping through the channels
as much as they used to, but they can still
catch a glimpse of him on TV.
Since 2015, Foxworthy has been the face and
voice of the Golden Corral buffet chain.
He's also made ads for Purina deer chow and
the iScope, an iPhone attachment that allows
hunters to take videos of whatever they see
through their gun's sight.
Most of these products fit into his down home
aesthetic, and he's also got his own marketplace
in play as well.
In 2011, he also started his own sports equipment
company called Foxworthy Outdoors.The company
sells a wide array of gear, including Jeff
Foxworthy Beef Jerky and "Redneck"-themed
T-shirts of course.
The storefront is also an umbrella under which
Foxworthy produces his series Inside & Out.
But he's not just in the business of selling
stuff these days.
Turning to philanthropy
For a guy who positioned himself as such a
salt-of-the-earth type of person, it's only
natural that he should put his money where
his mouth is.
So, Foxworthy has made good use of his fame
and fortune over the years by investing in
several charitable endeavors.
It starts at home, as Foxworthy Outdoors helps
fund hunting trips on Foxworthy's land preserve
for wounded soldiers and children with life-threatening
illnesses.
Plus, in 2012, he granted a local land trust
a conservation easement over 1000 acres of
his property in Georgia to protect the property
from construction.
And for more than a decade, the comedian and
his family have worked with a humanitarian
aid organization called Compassion International,
even traveling to Rwanda to help in and around
the organization's development center.
Another cause Foxworthy goes out of his way
to support is Cure Childhood Cancer, an organization
based near his home in Atlanta.
And for locals around his hometown, he's been
known to pick up the tab on a grocery bill
when things got tight, too.
Continuing his career
While it might seem like Jeff Foxworthy has
disappeared from the spotlight, he's still
very busy.
Logging all those hours on the stage and on
TV made Foxworthy's voice as recognizable
as his face and name, so in recent years,
he's lent his high-pitched drawl to a bunch
of animated projects, including The Smurfs,
Hatched, Ozzy, and Bunyan and Babe.
"Well, I'll be smurfed."
And in 2013, CMT aired 13 episodes of Bounty
Hunters, an animated sitcom about a small-town
bail bonds business starring Foxworthy alongside
his old Blue Collar Comedy Tour-mates.
Plus, after hosting Are You Smarter than a
Fifth Grader? for five seasons, Jeff Foxworthy
continued to frequent the reality competition
circuit as well.
He appeared in in two episodes of ABC's Shark
Tank and headlined the American adaptation
of Britain's The Great British Bake Off for
a single season at CBS.
He also hosted The American Bible Challenge,
which tested people's familiarity with the
titular book.
Meanwhile, his stand-up career is still ticking
along strong, too.
Foxworthy continues to tour the nation with
his signature phrases, playing a number of
dates each year at fairs, comedy clubs, and
casinos.
And in 2017, he co-headlined Jeff & Larry's
Backyard BBQ tour with Larry the Cable Guy.
The pair also teamed up to make a special
for Netflix called We've Been Thinking, wherein
he announced that he might have a new career
path altogether in mind.
"Well, I haven't decided if I'm running for
President or not yet…"
In other words, we haven't heard the last
of Jeff Foxworthy just yet.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!